so let's sum up where we are so far
we're looking at this formula and trying
to understand why it corresponds to
curvature why it tells you how much a
curve actually curves and the first
thing we did is we noticed that this
numerator corresponds to a certain cross
product the cross product between the
first derivative and the second
derivative of the function
parameterizing the curve
and the way we started to understand
that is we say well the function
parameterizing the curve s of t produces
vectors whose tips trace out that curve
itself
and now if you think about how one tip
moves to the next the direction that it
needs to go
for that tip to move to the next one
that's what the first derivative tells
you and when you treat that in an
infinitesimal way this is why you get
tangent vectors along the curve and
there's a there's an entire series of
videos on that for the derivative of a
position vector-valued function and they
explain why the first derivative of a
parametric function gives you tangent
vectors to that curve
but if we draw all of those tangent
vectors just in their own space their
own little s prime of t space
you get all of these vectors and we're
rooting them at the same point to be
able to relate them more easily the way
that you move from the tip of one of
those to the next one is given by the
second derivative it kind of plays the
same role for the first derivative as
the first derivative plays for the
original parametric function and
specifically if you have a circumstance
where the tangent vectors are just
turning the only thing they're doing is
purely turning around which is when your
curve is actually curving
this corresponds to a case when the
second derivative function is pretty
much perpendicular as a vector the
vector it produces is perpendicular to
the first derivative vector
so this is loosely why the cross product
is kind of a good measure of curving
because it tells you how perpendicular
these guys are but there's a bit of a
catch the original formula for curvature
the whole reason we're doing it with
respect to arc length and not with
respect to the parameter t
is that curvature doesn't really care
about how you parametrize the function
if you imagine zipping along it really
quickly so your tangent your first
derivative vectors are all super long it
shouldn't matter compared to crawling
along it like a turtle the curvature
should just always be the same
but this is a problem if you think back
to the cross product that we're now
looking at where you're taking the cross
product between the
the first derivative and the second
derivative because if you were traveling
along this curve twice as quickly what
that would mean is your first derivative
vector so i'll kind of draw it again
over here
would be twice as long to indicate that
you're going twice as fast and similarly
your second derivative vector to kind of
keep up with that changing rate would
also be twice as long
and as a result the parallelogram that
they trace out i should actually
kind of going off screen here
the parallelogram that they trace out
would be actually four times as big
right because both of the vectors um get
scaled up so the way that the way that
we really want to be thinking about this
is not the tangent vector due to the
derivative but normalizing this and this
should kind of make sense because we're
thinking in terms of unit tangent
vectors for the curvature as a whole so
if you imagine instead kind of cutting
off the vector
to make sure that it's got a unit length
a length of one and what that means is
you're taking the derivative vector and
dividing it by its own magnitude by the
magnitude of that derivative vector and
then similarly we'll want to scale
everything else down so you're taking
this
and kind of scaling it down by what you
need
the resulting parallelogram they trace
out is a more pure measurement of how
perpendicular they are without without
caring about how long they are and what
this guy would be by the way then this
is the second derivative vector
not normalized with respect to itself
but we're still dividing you know the
thing we're dividing by as we scale
everything down is still just the size
of that first derivative vector so this
cross product if we take the cross
product between
s prime
normalized
s double prime
no no no sorry
s prime itself and i should be saying
vectors for all of these these are all
vectors if we take the cross product
between that
and s double prime
scaled down by that same value that's
still s prime so it's not normalized
this is just scaled down by s prime
this here is a more pure measurement of
how perpendicular the second derivative
vector is to the first and the reason we
don't really care about the second
derivative being normalized is if it was
the case that you know the second
derivative was really really strong and
wasn't necessarily a unit vector that's
fine that's just telling us that the
tangent vector turns much more quickly
and the curvature should be higher and
in fact
it turns out that this whole expression
is
the derivative of the unit tangent
vector t that unit tangent vector that
i've talked about a lot with respect to
the parameter t
um so whatever whatever the parameter of
your original function is and now if you
think back to the i'm not sure if it was
the last video or the one before that
but i talked about how when you take
when we're looking for this derivative
of the tangent vector with respect to
arc length the way that you compute this
is to first take its derivative with
respect to the parameter which is
something we can actually do because
everything is expressed in terms of that
parameter and then dividing it by
the
basically the change in arc length with
respect to that parameter which is the
size of that first derivative function
so if this whole thing is the derivative
of the tangent vector with respect to t
what that means is when we take this and
we divide that whole thing
by
the derivative by s prime
that should give us curvature and in
fact that's just worth writing on its
own here that's that's curvature
curvature is equal to and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take since we see
this three different times we see you
know s the magnitude of s prime here
magnitude of s prime here magnitude of s
prime here since we see that three times
i'm going to go over here and i'm going
to put that on the denominator but cube
again so s prime
that derivative vector the magnitude of
that derivative vector cubed and then on
the top we still have s prime
that vector s prime cross product with s
double prime
that vector and this this is i mean you
could think of this as yet another
formula for curvature i think i've given
you like four at this point or you could
think of it as just kind of the same
thing and
if we look back up to our original one
that i was trying to justify
this is just the spelled out version of
it because what is this bottom component
here if we take x prime squared plus y
prime squared and if we think of the
square root of that so kind of taking it
to the one-half power that would be the
magnitude of the derivative and i and i
kind of showed that in in some of the
previous videos and what we're doing is
we're cubing that so that whole formula
that's the very explicit you know in
terms of x and y's what's going on is
really just expressing this idea you
take the cross product between the first
derivative and the second derivative and
then because you're normalizing it you
know normalizing with respect to the
first derivative you want to scale down
the second derivative by that same
amount just so that the parallelogram
we're thinking kind of shrinks and
everything stays in proportion and then
once again we're dividing about that s
prime basically because curvature is
supposed to be with respect to s and not
with respect to t so that's a way of
kind of
getting a correction factor for how
wrong you're going to be if you just
think in terms of the parameter t
instead of steps in terms of the arc
length
so hopefully this makes the the original
formula a little bit less random seeming
you know in this two-dimensional case
and it also gives another strong
conceptual tool for understanding
yet another way that you can think about
how much a curve itself actually curves
and i think i've i've probably done
enough videos here going through all the
different formulas for what curvature
should be
and then in the next one or two i'll go
through some specific examples just to
see what it looks like to to compute
that